this video is sponsored by book Walker
new season new year new decade and
looking over the seasonal chart I can
already see change in horizon
that's right unless we're counting
virtual mmo's there is actually no new
original Easter Kai this time so that's
why we can start off 2020 with the only
Issei Kai sequel airing right now that's
right everyone give it up to now flew me
and the shield hero cast carrying on the
East kite torch as they joined Easter
guy quartet everyone [ __ ] gets it also
don't you think I caused it too - who
the [ __ ] of this name do you even know
what that means
it's an ensemble of all four how many
new series do we have now
fine oh if only there was a one for an
ensemble - fine oh wait there is I wish
I owned the dictionary in you with the
word quinjets man it's not like we have
5 Series in the East High Court X now
yeah keep doing what you're doing
welcome to the quartet dude go [ __ ]
yourself
[Music]
let's open up to one of the most
interesting concepts this season a guy
wakes up to a broken world with no
knowledge of who he is or where he came
from he walks around and finds the dead
body who he somehow recognizes and
instinctively knows he must solve the
murder as we have presented more
information we find out this Ward has
been constructed from the subconscious
mind of a murderer and by watching this
detective piece together the twisted
logic of this world it gives real-time
information on the location and identity
of the killer that the police can use
this is a detective mystery that seems
like a mix between Psychopaths persona
and minority reports it almost feels
like a long-lost ghetto a booty show of
the 2010s and I'm looking forward to
seeing how they explored this premise
because it's just refreshing to see new
and original ideas in anime the kanji
for Edo can also mean other and earth
put those together and you get other
world
don't do this to me GOx to the wall
[Music]
shadow legend looks like we have another
death game anime this time revolving
around a mobile game that gives you
special abilities gaining unwilling
participants to anyone foolish enough to
open the app if you've seen any death
game shows this one basically follows
that mirai nikki former to the team
except this one has a yandere love
interest who doesn't have pink hair wait
a minute illegal it's a cheating stupid
but it's the entertaining kind of edgy
and stupid where if you can just turn
your brain off you can have fun with all
the stupid things happening on screen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this is probably gonna be my trash
show of the season
all right through the usual quick
rundown with the sequels available the
boys are back in town cuz it's haikyuu
season four and I'm pretty hype railguns
back Madoka has a spin-off series based
on a mobile game that came out I don't
know too much about the game this time
so I don't have much say except look
it's baby QB oh what a cute baby
serves you right mapa 2019 Doh doh-doh
snappa 2020 dodo-head dodo snapper 2021
[Music]
this is my first time hearing of dodo
head Dodos I had absolutely no idea was
getting myself into
I thought I watched the lizard guy
swallow someone's head to see if a man
living inside the lizard's mouth would
recognized the face before dicing him up
into little pieces and I was like all
right I have absolutely no idea what I'm
getting myself into but this is one that
certainly stands out from the rest of
the shows this season the dystopian
gritty world instantly caught my
attention at along with how
unflinchingly vicious it is yeah it's
not exactly studio orange level 3d but
it's certainly not enough to put me off
hell it's easier to stomach from how
damn brutal can get sometimes so you
have been warned
[Music]
they go on beyond this game called rate
shadow legends it's a done based MMO
this show is bad like I'd like to think
we've grown past a point where main
character straights up groping a girl
should be seen as a charming trait cause
he's a cool-looking protagonist but I
also don't know how I'm supposed to feel
sorry for a girl he's just so annoyingly
stupid enough to fall for the anime
equivalent of hey kid want to come into
my van for some free candy I see nothing
wrong in that
this isn't free candy and it's a shame
because you know what this actually has
a semi interesting concept in world with
some of the most unlikable characters
you can think of so is that enough for
me to stick with it no pop quiz tell me
what these three things have in common
watching a man dedicates years of his
life to beat a world record of an arcade
game nobody plays anymore and Lassa
physicists talking about origami keep
your hands off a token and this guy who
can pound mochi at an unreasonably fast
pace that's right
seeing passionate people do the things
they love passionately is just an
absolute joy to watch keep your hands up
Isaac kun is the latest project from
masaaki yuasa of devil man crybaby ping
pong the animation and a whole load of
other great [ __ ] this one follows a
story of a bunch of animation nerds who
former clubs make anime and the entire
process around that before you write
this off as something that wouldn't
interest you at least give the first
episode of watch because the scene that
sold me was in episode 1 where a pair of
them are just going over some rough
concept art and they come across this
basic sketch of some ship what starts
off as a throwaway sketch takes you on
this entire journey as they start adding
detail discussing Howard operates what
setting the wood inhabit the sounds it
would make a whole world is invented
around this single concept and before
you know it you are sucked into this
wondrous world of imagination with them
what I said earlier about watching
passionate people goes for the actual
characters and you asked her himself
with this show there's a magic in
watching people do the things they love
I've been utterly enthralled by video
subjects I couldn't care
about because the people presenting it
engrossed you in their world and you for
a brief period can understand why they
love the things they love I feel that
with this show you can have no interest
in how anime is made but it's presented
to you in such a wondrous veteran
passion that you can't help but be
infected by it this was immediately a
contender for anime of the season and
once again shows that you are sir it's
just really good at what he does
speaking of shows about following your
passion smile down the runway is [ __ ]
lit and not enough people are watching
it I admit when I saw this premise with
some pretty average looking production
values I thought it wasn't gonna be my
thing but now I am absolutely addicted
to this show it's an anime bus fashion
design and modelling but it's done in
the style of a shown in sports anime and
if the Sports anime formula has taught
me anything is that it can take a
subject I have absolutely no interest in
and make me completely invested in it
you've got an on the dog story you've
got training arcs you've even got slight
power scaling showing off in the form of
Instagram followers which just made me
think man if this formula works for
anything what would it be like we had a
battle anime where the power system
itself was just clout this pressure I've
never sensed anything like it before
hey what does the social blade say about
his Klout level it's over 9 million
followers
what nine million impossible I've never
even seen him before
you fools I haven't even done a face
reveal yet this is my toughest opponent
yet
this technique a Chompy this video is
sponsored he wouldn't buy rabbit poker
hey did you know that book Walker is the
official katak our ebook store for all
catechol titles and Beyond including
inspector small down the runway and yes
even in two species reviews
if you're a new user you can also use
coupon code Giga for five dollars off
yeah I've never said that before so get
on down to book Walker and you can raise
a new manga and light novel today all
right back to the video we've got our
fair share of the supernatural of the
season first well it's found Hanukkah
curling is about to toilet spirits we
help solves a little girl's problem
before good things about the manga and
after watching the first episode then
there's also inspector which is another
mystery detective type show around
supernatural apparitions there was
something that drew me to this
immediately it is the instant chemistry
between the two main leads there was
just something mesmerizing about their
dialogue in the show it's it's in this
weird limbo area where you know no one
in real life actually interacts like
this but it's so punchy and unique that
it draws you in and entertains you and
it's ironic because I found it more
interesting when they were just
bullshitting about absolutely nothing
than talking about actual plot points if
you're looking for something sweet and
wholesome this season then I highly
recommend Somali in the forest spirit I
put this in the anime category of Japan
going hey you see this isn't this cute
this is baby baby is nice baby is cute
baby give you love baby give you life
who doesn't want baby I want baby please
make baby details a golem who finds a
lost human child in a fantasy world
where humans are an endangered species
and goes on a journey to help the kid
find their parents it's simple yet just
really well done and seeing an anime
like this reminds you what a fantasy
world with strange and wonderful
creatures can be like and that there's
more to world building in a fantasy
setting than just
my job here is done
[Music]
I didn't [ __ ] my cat I didn't come on my
cat I didn't put my dick anywhere near
my cat I've never done anything weird
with my cats I promised myself I wasn't
going to make apology videos after last
year's things so I'm just trying to be
as short and honest with this as
possible on the latest episode of now
that's what I call culture Mecca para
has finally gotten a full anime
adaptation if you want to see cute cat
girls doing cute things cuz I mean who
doesn't love watching cats if you've
never heard of nekopara before it's
based on the visual novel there has a
bit of a infamous background so some
alarm bells might be ringing when you
see some of the youngest felines being
like nine months old or are they see
those of us with a high enough IQ know
that these are actually cat years I mean
this is just a rap Tahlia argument all
over again so to prove the doubters once
and for all I have conducted a thorough
investigation to show the legal and
moral ramifications of such cat girls
exact conversion numbers do vary from
source to source but through my research
we can still get a rough idea of the
equivalent and more important human age
and so through pure science and math we
can conclude that her age is actually
something closer to oh oh no
I'm gonna be honest though despite the
questionable background this was
actually pretty tame fanservice wise
yeah I know but a slide from a few
scenes it's mostly just wholesome fun
especially compared to some of the other
stuff we've been seeing if this is
really the worst anime has to offer
right now
maybe anime has started the new decade
by turning over a new leaf turning over
a new leaf
[Music]
[Music]
most of our travel single men who
masturbate to anime at first you had my
curiosity but now you have my erection
[Laughter]
they did it mahat lad did it alright I'm
getting ahead of myself
how can I describe this show imagine
Ravi brah had a squad but instead of
going round reviewing different
fast-food joints they went around
sleeping with a bunch of monster girl
prostitutes and reviewing the smash
that's it that's the show
my disappointment is non-existent my
maid you know for real that's actually
pretty damn funny if you find what the
concepts being what it is but the real
thing I want to appreciate is the new
achievement this show has made as we
know anime has recently been pushing the
boundary with what it can get away with
but this show is taking it so far by
essentially just showing full-on sex
scenes
Funimation actually dropped it because
it fell outside of their company
standards and the Japanese Network Tokyo
MX has full-on cancelled the television
broadcast on their channel here in Japan
that's right we've finally done it we
can no longer tell the difference
between anime and hentai remember this
well because this is a moment that will
go down in anime history and I just want
to take a moment to appreciate this
momentous occasion as we can finally
witness the evolution of anime and the
birth of a new genre as we enter this
new
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much I'm so proud
of you all
[Applause]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much for daddy book
Walker for sponsoring me again today you
can click the link below to find all the
source material they have for all the
airing shows this season and with that
said thank you very much - we biologists
Ricky zob mondo BDD in your life damas
pa Tata Walter Lau cam and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
this month also just a quick
announcement but this summer I will be
intending smash Con in Sydney Australia
on the 18th and 19th of July I think
it's gonna be my very first time in
Australia so I'm pretty excited so um
yeah hope to see any of your Z's out
there anyway that's it from me no
further updates today I finger got and I
will see you all next time